Vsauce, Kevin here.
On November 15th, 1912,
an innocent family
moved into a large, rambling house
with narrow windows
seemingly incapable
of welcoming the sun's rays.
Soon after, the sound
of a door slamming shut by itself
and footsteps inside the walls
terrified the parents.
The children heard voices—
someone, or something,
called out from beyond,
and all of the plants
withered and died.
This house truly was haunted
by carbon monoxide.
The furnace was broken,
filling the entire home
with poisonous gas,
causing headaches, dizziness,
and auditory hallucinations,
but not ghosts.
What the FAK?
The facts and knowledge
on (not so) real ghosts.
A legendary ghost ship known
as the Flying Dutchman
roamed the waters, collecting the souls
of those who died at sea.
Witnessing the phantom vessel
sailing the sky above the water
was an omen of doom—
a sign you'd never see land again.
What sailors were actually seeing, however,
was a superior mirage effect
known as Fata Morgana.
Light reflecting off cold water
can be bent
by an unusual layer
of warm air above,
making a normal ship look
like a ghostly, glowing ship
that's sailing inside a wave
or flying over the sea.
Reports of poltergeist activity
often reveal themselves
to be the work
of kids throwing household objects
when their parents aren't looking,
and purported haunted hotels
have been busted having employees perform
many not-so-paranormal activities,
such as flicking the lights
on and off.
But in 1973,
the Knocking Ghost of Boise
baffled police and frightened a woman
and her daughter.
The ghost
could successfully answer questions,
like how many people
were in the room,
by rapping on the floorboards,
a knock so forceful
the officers felt the vibration
in the soles of their shoes.
They couldn't explain the ghost
in the crawl space.
A news team came to investigate
and noticed the ghost
only knocked when the woman stood
in a certain peculiar way.
When confronted, she admitted
an abnormal condition in her ankle
caused a loud knocking sound
when she flexed her leg muscle.
The mystery of the knocking ghost
was just a messed up ankle.
Bloody Mary is a legend
whereby staring into a mirror
in a room lit only by candlelight
and repeating the name
will summon her apparition.
Originally, this ritual was performed
by a young woman
hoping to see the face
of her future husband,
and if she saw a skull instead,
it meant she would die before being married.
Staring into a mirror
in a dimly-lit room
can cause the Caputo Effect,
or strange face illusion,
which distorts
our face-specific interpretation system,
really making it look
like another face is in the mirror.
But whether you think
it's your future husband
or Queen Mary the First
is up to you.
The science
behind understanding haunt events
that don't have logical explanations,
like a bum ankle
or an optical illusion,
is currently not so clear cut.
We know that magnetic fields
can cause hallucinations
that result in rushes of fear
and experiencing apparitions.
This has led to the suggestion
that haunted locations
may actually contain
anomalous magnetic fields,
which induce hallucinations,
thereby causing haunt events.
But a lot more research is needed
to prove this theory.
Psychologist Richard Wiseman suggests
infrasonic vibrations
as a cause for ghost sightings.
Infrasound is lower in frequency
than human hearing,
but can be felt
in parts of the body.
For instance, it can cause
an eyeball to resonate,
making it appear
like a mysterious object
is floating in your periphery,
but when you turn to look, it's gone.
An infrasound around 19 hertz
can cause feelings of fear and shivering.
But even so, magnetic fields
and infrasound
are external triggers
creating unknown sights and sounds
that human brains may then interpret
as coming from the supernatural,
because we're obsessed
with giving agency to the unexplained,
seeing human-like behavior
in meaningless stimuli.
Psychologists in the 1940s
set up an experiment
in which they showed people
a meaningless cartoon
of a large triangle, small triangle,
and circle
moving in and out of a box.
Instantly, people created detailed stories
about the shapes,
such as the circle being in love
with the little triangle,
with the big triangle trying
to steal the circle away,
constructing a meaning
for something devoid of one.
So with illusions, gas leaks,
and inaudible sound waves,
will science eventually bust
all of the ghosts,
or just leave us alone in the dark
with whatever is left out there?
And as always,
thanks for watching.
[Vsauce 2]
[Welcome to YouTube House of Horrors]
[A Legendary Halloween]
[buzzing sounds]
[booming sound]